[Musique]
m
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti pour le sommaire
en football dans le championnat de
première division de district maurepas
s'est imposé ce dimanche face à
montesson à domicile le score 3 à 0 le
résumé du match dans quelques instants
découverte aujourd'hui coup de
projecteur sur la cryothérapie une
technique de soins par le froid utilisé
par les sportifs ou recevront dans ce
magazine l'un des précurseurs philippe
cros un spécialiste installe à
versailles qui travaillent avec des
structures professionnelles rugby un
club écossais est venu jouer ce samedi
23 février un match à plaisir dans le
cadre du tournoi des six nations au tour
sur cette rencontre amicale dans ce
magazine l'actualité sportive de la
semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78 on
commence donc par du football en match
en retard de première division de
district maurepas s'est imposé ce
dimanche face à montesson à domicile
grâce à un triplé de son attaquant
vedette et jakub belfodil le résumé du
match à remontage de exergian maurepas
et monte son se sont retrouvés ce
dimanche 24 février en match en retard
du championnat de d1 de district à
domicile les mauraciens prennent
rapidement le jeu à leur compte et
arrive à conclure dans le premier quart
d'heure grâce à yakubu belfodil
montesson réagi thiery minutes plus tard
sur la barre à ils se sont finalement
les verts qui arrive à faire le break
grâce à leur numéro 9 le joueur est
proche d'inscrire un triplé quelques
minutes plus tard mais échoue 2 à 0 à la
mi temps on a la chance de marquer très
tôt dans le match pendant on est bien
rentré dans le match on est on est
concentrés on a le ballon joue bien donc
on est content malgré que
vous pouvez mettre encore de plus je
pense tu vois là c'est bonne première
mi-temps dans l'ensemble mais faut faire
mieux en deuxième période pour vraiment
plier le match et les maîtres mettre le
moral à zéro l'équipe adverse
au retour des vestiaires mort pas se
voir refuser deux buts dont un pur enjeu
montesson pousse ensuite pour revenir
dans le match et s'offrent une grosse
occasion en milieu de seconde période
mais ce sont finalement les morlaisiens
qui arrivent à se mettre à l'abri avec
un troisième but inscrit par
l'inarrêtable et jakub belfodil sur ce
lob montesson tentera de réduire le
score mais la défense des verts tient
bon score final 3 à 0
votre but en temps surtout pour la
victoire aussi a fait ça fait du bien de
renouer avec la victoire à domicile
devant nos supporters donc on est
content and content
défensivement aussi tout le monde était
concentré dans les duels on a mis le
point d'impact ont été été solide on est
bien ressortir proprement toujours de
prendre 0 buts dans un match ça fait
toujours plaisir
être fort dans la tête aussi maintenant
on peut faire mieux encore on fait
quelques encore quelques petites voulait
encore quelques soucis à régler quoi
avec cette victoire maurepas remonte à
la 5e place du classement et s'éloigne
de la zone de relégation
prochain match le 10 mars sur le terrain
de gargenville toujours en football mais
cette fois ci dans le championnat de
régionale 3 trap est toujours invaincu
cette saison les trappistes sont allés
s'imposer sur le terrain de nice ce week
end sur le score de 2 buts à 0 avec
cette victoire trappe conserve la
première place du championnat avec un
petit point d'avancé sur boulogne
billancourt après 14 journées disputées
football toujours mais cette fois ci
dans le championnat de 2e division de
district ce dimanche les
clayes-sous-bois se sont inclinés sur
leur terrain contre conflans match en
retard une défaite qui n'arrange pas les
clis tient toujours relégable après
douze journées avec seulement deux
victoires depuis le début de la saison
au compteur on continue par du volley
ball les féminines de l'ess monte
volet-là la vsv easy volley ball qui
évolue en nationale 3 se sont imposés 3
sets à 1 ce week-end contre le sporting
club paris volé une victoire qui leur
permet de remonter à la deuxième place
du classement pour nous parler de ce
résultat nous recevons sur ce plateau
l'entraîneur laurent vernay ainsi que
deux joueuses noren rio est ainsi qu'à
nice vega bonsoir
alors on va revenir d'abord sur le match
de ce week-end comment s'est déroulée
cette partie c'était une bonne équipe de
paris
effectivement très offensive et on a
réussi à jouer juste tout le long du
match
beaucoup d'engagement beaucoup d'efforts
dans le jeu arrière est vraiment une
équipe qui a réussi à bien communiquer à
jouer ensemble et même dans les moments
durs parce que ça peut être facile tout
le long du match mais même quand on
n'était pas bien on était dans le rouge
on n'a pas senti l'équipe se disloquer
on est resté soudé
donc franchement c'est un peu la force
ce week-end noël vous avez le même
sentiment sentiment on a retrouvé une
cohésion d'équipé mais l'énergie qui est
vraiment collective et c'est ça qui a
été notre force ce week-end faut le dire
clairement
alors je rappelle le score 25 21 dans le
premier set paris égalise dans le
deuxième set 25 15 puis vous remporter
les deux sets suivants 25 20 et 25 23
c'était une victoire qu'il fallait aller
chercher vrai qu'on a été amené aux
scores parfois et on a su remonter la
pente est vraiment tout ensemble on a on
a on a gagné 3,7 et ça fait vraiment
plaisir de retrouver la cohésion qu'on
avait quelque peu perdu depuis quelques
semaines vous avez douté à un set
partout
eux n'ont donc probablement parce que
même le sept compères même 25 15 on le
perd mais on joue en fait c'est juste
l'adversaire qui a été plus forte dans
les duels
donc à partir de là on a joué notre jeu
et même si on devait perdre les deux
sets suivants en jouant comme ça c'était
notre niveau sauf que à un moment donné
l'adversaire a pas réussi à tenir nous
on a été plus régulier sur l'ensemble
des deux deux derniers sets qu'est-ce
qui a fait la différence vraiment cette
partie c'est l'esprit l'équipe
tout à fait c'est là comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure la cohésion en fait cette
énergie elle est vraiment moteur dans le
jeu on voit le jeu est bien plus propre
du coup la technique ça ça avant
aussi c'est bien plus simple de
construire quand il ya plus de cohésion
en plus d'entente et de communication
comme l'a dit notre couche alors c'était
une équipe qui vous devancé au
classement avant cette journée c'était
un match couperet on peut on peut le
dire comment vous l'avez appréhender ce
match on sortait de fin on était dans
une phase un peu délicate
on était en train de perdre des matches
un peu important on n'arrivait pas à
rejouer ensemble et c'est vrai qu'on a
eu une semaine d'entraînement un petit
peu compliqué on a poussé un petit peu
il ya eu des réactions de la part des
choses je passais pas ressenti
directement donc c'était important de
gagner mais surtout c'était important de
bien jouer et que l'équipe se retrouve
sur le terrain
donc c'est surtout ça la priorité de ce
week-end et on a eu la victoire au bout
donc sauté top mais il se faisait pas
senti une pression particulière pour ce
match un an vraiment pour nous
l'essentiel c'était de retrouver le
plaisir d'un jeu et c'est ce qu'on est
parvenu à faire et bien sûr la victoire
au bout sans la cerise sur le gâteau et
c'est ce pour quoi on se bat et on
s'entraîne toutes les semaines donc le
plaisir avant tout alors vous restez sur
une défaite 3 sets à 0 contre une équipe
du milieu de tableau
comment avez vous fait pour vous
remobiliser j'étais le bruit de travail
ya eu un entraînement mardi
particulièrement douloureux pour les
filles pas physiquement mais
psychologiquement je les ai poussé un
petit peu à sortir deux de leurs
habitudes enfin là donc on l'a bien
sortis de leur zone de confort ça a
explosé un petit peu et ça leur a fait
du bien pour après se retrouver en fait
c'est un peu dur mais un psycho
logiquement mardi elles ont elles ont
éclaté on va dire c'est ça le plus de
satisfaction du coup sûr cette victoire
et du coup oui effectivement vendredi
l'entraînement s'est bien déroulé et je
pense que l on réussit à retrouver les
notions de individuel d'engagement qu'on
avait un peu perdu
je alors vous êtes maintenant deuxièmes
du championnat à deux points de la
première place
vous pensiez pouvoir rêver à ce niveau
là à ce moment là à ce moment là de la
saison
c'est dire qu'on a fait une très bonne
partie de saison 20 premières parties
pendant deux saisons où on était
invaincu sauf le match contre orléans
donc automatiquement je suis dit qu'on
va continuer dans cette danse même élan
et c'est sûr que le coup dur ça nous a
un petit peu ralenti dans cette danse
est poussé mais on garde quand même cet
objectif de rester au tableau donc oui
pourquoi pas en effet on continue là
dedans et c'est pas une surprise la
première place la 2e place la 3e période
arrivée sur le podium
la première place ça sera normalement
inatteignable parce que même si on est à
deux points derrière
agglo sud est la raison de match sur
moins de nous donc théoriquement elles
sont plus loin devant et c'est comme une
très grosse équipe l'aller on les avait
attrapé au premier match c'est prémâche
base est en reconstruction nous c'était
la même équipe de la dernière donc on
les a eus parce qu'on savait jouer
ensemble et sur le match retour
elles nous ont cueilli comme il fallait
on a été un peu moins bon et dans une
très bonne équipe
le sud après les autres équipes oui un
moyen de rester devant mais il faut
penser que vous pouvez monter cette
saison où ça sera encore un petit peu
compliqué ça que c'est une première
année en n3 donc l'objectif de la montée
n'était pas forcément
l'objectif initial du groupe après bien
sûr si on peut aller la chercher la
montée ben prat tout pour mais c'est pas
l'objectif numéro 1 en tout cas alors
pour aller chercher cette montée il
faudra battre ce week-end châteaudun qui
est un mal classé
forcément il faudra pas se manquer c'est
exactement ça et donc c'est avec cette
semaine ont fait que des matches amicaux
justement pour repartir dans le jeu
comme on a fait dimanche retrouvez le
plaisir là la façon de bien jouer
ensemble
donc pour justement à châteaudun être
sûr d'avoir les bonnes notions
collective on va voir un petit pronostic
avant de se quitter sur châteaudun on va
y aller 3-0 3-0
vous êtes unanimes là-dessus
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau vous
souhaite de terminer le plus haut
possible dans ce championnat de
nationale 3 ans suivra votre parcours
avec attention sur tv 78 merci beaucoup
merci nous avons invité un goût de
basket à présentera pas chuté à
l'extérieur dans le choc contre le
leader
les trappistes ont perdu contre poitiers
lors de la 16e journée du championnat de
nationale 3 défaites 98 à 82 pour les
trappistes au classement les saint
quentinois voit s'échapper la première
place ils ont quatre points de retard
sur leur adversaire du jour toujours en
basket mais cette fois ci à chez les
féminines le chesnay-versailles continue
sa marche en avant dans le championnat
de nationale 3 les joueuses de vinko
berdych se sont facilement imposés
contre angers ce dimanche le score est
sans appel 65 à 45 lui lcv 78 conserve
sa première place devant le havre avec
un bilan de 15 victoires pour une seule
défaite cette saison on prend maintenant
la direction de plaisir un match inédit
s'est déroulée ce week end dans la
commune l'équipe locale affronter les
joueurs écossais en parallèle du tournoi
des six nations des images d'aurélie
ronsard montage de et xavier genre d
entraîneur en kilt c'était l'image
insolite de ce samedi 23 février au
stade robert barran de plaisir le club
écossais de nine 10 go est venu
affronter sur le terrain une équipe
composée de joueurs locaux dans le cadre
d'un partenariat créé en parallèle du
tournoi des six nations
sur le terrain les français l'emportent
38 à 24
on a beau faire la fête la veille sur le
terrain il ya pu y a plus d'amitié
pendant deux fois quarante minutes donc
bon match c'était un match très dur
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'essais pour les
deux équipes très agréable très dur
beaucoup de joueurs ont été en
difficulté aujourd'hui mais nous allons
passer un bon moment après le match ce
rendez vous était également l'occasion
pour les français de comparer leur jeu à
celui des écossais je dirais engagé et
mobile c'est des joueurs assez mobile
assez léger qui se déplace beaucoup
donc voilà c'est pas comme les jeux
français où on a plus plus l'habitude
d'avoir d'avoir des gros de fixer là
c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus rapide
ça joue sajou énormément ce partenariat
organisé pour la première fois plaisir a
convaincu les dirigeants du club c'est
bien parce que ça je pense qu'on peut
développer des échanges ne serait ce
qu'avec aller une fois tous les deux ans
donc ce qui se passe avec moi leur
entente là peut même prévoir d'y aller
avec des jeunes minimes des cadets une
belle expérience pour rencontrer
d'autres cultures
après avoir déjeuné ensemble les joueurs
sont ensuite allés voir le match du
quinze de france face aux quinze du
chardon stade de france et là aussi les
français l'ont emporté
je vous propose à présent de découvrir
la cryothérapie pour les sportifs pour
nous présenter cette technique de soin
par le froid nous recevons sur ce
plateau l'un des précurseurs de cette
technique en france philippe cros
bonsoir bonsoir
alors avant de parler de votre activité
qui est basé à satory qu'est ce que
c'est la cryothérapie alors la
cryothérapie est un traitement par le
froid un froid extrême parce qu'on
descend pendant trois minutes à -150
degrés là c'est à pour tout ce qui est
récupération c'est quelque chose de très
important c'est utilisé au départ parce
pour ça et c'est un ancien fleuron
traumatologie s'est énormément utilisé
aussi c'est un anti inflammatoire
naturel un antalgique très puissant un
entier de matelas anti stress
un antalgique et donc un anti-infectieux
aussi donc il ya un panel de patients
très important et si vous avez donné
envie de vous lancer dans cette activité
c'est la connaissance j'ai eu la chance
de rencontrer le dr gérard guillaume qui
est l'ancien médecin des équipes
cyclistes de la française française des
jeux donc et pour les grands tours il
voulait de la cryothérapie
et donc c'est parti comme ça il a voulu
avoir un camion puis voilà j'ai connu la
clio par ce biais là en 2011
alors avec qui travailler bouffe j'ai
travaillé la grippe a et de nombreux
sportifs
j'ai la chance de faire cette fois le
tour de france cinq fois le tour
d'espagne avec la française des jeux de
faire deux fois le tour d'italie
une fois avec une équipe italienne deux
fois était une équipe italienne
j'étais sur la coupe du monde du rugby
avec l'équipe de france pendant un mois
en angleterre et au pays de galles en
2015 j'ai fait l'euro de football avec
l'équipe d'irlande en 2010 n'a en 2016
je travaille plus le rugby club de
toulon avec le stade français à fin 2016
à versailles en jeu rappelle l'équipe de
diarrhée on était réservé si elle était
basée sur versailles dont je restais à
montbron je me suis déplacé à à comment
à lille quand ils ont juste content
italie puis contre l'équipe de france à
lyon donc voilà donc chez des clients
comme un petit peu prestigieux c'est mon
grand plaisir quoi le tour de france ça
fonctionne et comment quand vous étiez
sur le tour de france était après les
étapes
alors l'heure le camion et le mans je
faisais hôtel l'hôtel la cour je ne
voyais pas donc le matin il a auparavant
le petit déjeuner des faits leurs
séances de cryo une fois que les
sciences décrit otepää est fait je
rangeais de tout le camion et j'allais à
l'hôtel suivant et dès qu'ils arrivaient
après l'état avec leur bus
avant le passage aisé leur séance de
cryo on va en ce moment même votre
premier camion
vous aviez ici à montigny-le-bretonneux
au vélodrome national de saint-quentin
vous accompagner à ce moment là l'équipe
de france de bmx jeux genre de leur
donner un coup de main et sur le nouveau
à plusieurs reprises c'était à côté donc
c'était pratique pour eux est ce que la
technologie a changé le principe est
toujours le même
en 2012 les le principe le nom c'était
un petit peu plus tard ça devait en 2014
à peine 14 et donc pas ce qu'avaient les
droits en 2012 je crois qu'ils étaient
ailleurs victime peut pas sortir le
corps de terre non la technique et la
technologie est toujours là la technique
est toujours la même c'est l'exposition
froid les machines ont vraiment évolué
il ya des machines maintenant qu'ils
sont vraiment très performante là qu'il
tient avec malheureusement qui le sont
un peu moins et ça a fait quelques
accidents mais
bon voilà c'est ça bouge ça pas trop
bougé non plus alors votre activité est
maintenant basé à satory à versailles
dans un magasin fixe pourquoi pourquoi
avoir été votre cas mais j'ai toujours
les camions parce que je me déplace
chaque année je vais sur je travaillais
avec le stade français je travaillais en
cas de différents clubs je vais sur des
traits l'important aux à la 6000d à la
plagne je vais à ambazac pour les
gendarmes éleveurs du temps je fais une
autre
la plus grosse cycle au monde qui
s'appelle la haute route donc je vois là
je me déplace encore mais de plus en
plus de particuliers demande cette
technologie donc j'ai un centre qui est
basque et à marseille maintenant aussi
j'ai ouvert ce le centre de satory parce
que j'avais des gendarmes comme patients
qui viennent au vélodrome avec moi et
puis c'était plus facile
et puis voilà il ya une hyène peu plus
une population de particulière de
particuliers qui demandent de plus en
plus cette technologie nous sommes allés
justement dans votre magasin fixe à
satory on écoute les réactions c'est pas
instantanée mais après enfin moi c'est à
l'issue d'une opération je me suis fait
opérer des ligaments croisés c'est par
rapport à ça
pour avoir une meilleure récupération
suite à mon opération super comme d'hab
on appris en un peu mais c'est de la
sensation d'après donc mois après
certains gros aux entraînements va bien
là bas ça fait du bien c'est comme si tu
mettais ton ton encore dans un glaçon et
puis tant açores en tout cas je ressens
d'un de bons effets après ces réactions
vous surprennent non pas du tout non pas
du tout
c'est à partir du moment où vous avez
des clubs professionnels qui vous
contactent et avec qui vous travaillez
depuis plusieurs années si quelque part
il ya un résultat parce qu'ils n'ont pas
pour habitude de dépenser l'argent
n'importe comment donc et c'est le va
prendre l'exemple du rugby parce que
c'est le simple plaisir énorme pour moi
ç'a déjà un sport que j'aime beaucoup et
puis j'ai n'entraîne excellente approche
avec ses joueurs qui ont qui sont des
gens humbles et à vous allez dans le
bassin de glace les les poubelles de
glace et depuis qu'ils ont connu cette
technologie ils veulent plus aller dans
la glace donc et régulièrement il
m'appelle ils viennent le confort leur
niveau efficacité oui et le confort
aller dans une bassine dans une bassine
de glace je pense que vous avez à dire
essayer moi je me suis retrouvé une fois
dedans parce que j'ai pas le choix c'est
mathieu bastareaud qui m'a mis dedans
j'ai pas résisté et j'ai pas cherché à
résister non plus c'est froid c'est
froid et on met énormément de temps à se
réchauffer l' avantage de la cryos une
fois que c'est fini on se rhabille voilà
c'est pour une efficacité supérieure en
plus alors ça dure trois minutes pas
plus ça sert à rien elle est plus froid
d'un des plus longs et plus froid que
-150 degrés parce que le haut niveau
d'efficacité on ne donne pas grand chose
par contre on prend on peut prendre des
risques un peu plus important donc dans
trois minutes fort et -150 degrés c'est
le bon compromis
c'est reconnu par les médecins de plus
en plus de rubato nous envoie des
patients pour tout ce qui est pathologie
anti-inflammatoires tout ce qui est
secondaire tri de fibromyalgie ou et
c'est pour ça que moi je travaille
énormément partenariat avec les médecins
et je veux vraiment faire le un parcours
de
par un parcours de santé avec les
médecins je veux pas faire ça en solo
c'est pas bon mon avis on peut monter à
combien de degrés maximum je sais pas je
m'arrête à -150 degrés donc je veux pas
savoir si ça peut aller plus loin ou pas
tout le monde peut en faire
non on ne peut pas en faire parce qu'il
ya des contre indications
entre des contre-indications cardiaque
les gens qui ont un infarctus ou moins
de six mois de tensions non régulés les
personnes sondées
un pacemaker les personnes qui ont des
thromboses veineuses bon de la maladie
de raynaud des jantes urinaire geofroy
bien que de temps en temps il y en a qui
le font
prison valley rechute plutôt un froid
humide last un froid sec donc qu il ya
des contre indications mais toute façon
il faut il ya des visites visite
médicale à autorisation médicale donc
bon
combien ça coûte favre un équipement
comme le web c'était compliqué la
machine ça vaut aux alentours de 40
mille euros plus les l'équipement etc
donc j'ai pas vraiment calculé combien
et pour pratiquer ces sept cryothérapie
blanchir une séance est à 38 euros à
paris ce book plus cher moi j'essaie de
le mettre à un prix abordable façon à ce
que plus de personnes puissent le faire
et on descend on peut descendre à bada
30 euros voire moins en fonction du
quantitatif si c'est des clubs
enfin braga tout info je veux que je
veux vraiment que je veux pas que ce
soit simplement que à problèmes d'argent
c'est important l'argent pour une
entreprise parce que c'est là c'est la
vie de l'entreprise mais je veux pas que
ce soit un frein pour d'autres personnes
merci à vous cette victoire vous
souhaite bon courage et vous quel est
votre prochain événement le prochain
n'ont pas paru nice parce que le city
c'est un peu compliqué pour moi
continuer pour diverses raisons
mais bon il ya des équipes qui veulent
que qui voudraient bien que je vienne
moi je veux parler avec elle je
travaille de céder trail se faire des
trail des marathons des je me consacre
beaucoup à satory et sur juillet je vais
peut-être travaille pour eux sur joie
j'ai peut-être travailler sur la coupe
de monde de football féminin j'attends
de trois résultats mais je pense que ça
va faire beaucoup philippe saux la serva
lui aussi a fait le choix de se
ressourcer dans le froid dans le cadre
de sa préparation le skipper
rambolitains louis burton se prépare
physiquement non pas dans l'eau mais à
la montagne dans la station de l'alpe
d'huez
la navigateur alternance qui le squash
ou encore des séances techniques en
salles un travail intensif en vue de sa
prochaine échéance la transat jacques
vabre une course transatlantique entre
le havre et le brésil
rendez vous programmé le 27 octobre
prochain son bateau au bureau vallée 2
est lui en pleine préparation on ouvre
une page jeux olympiques de 2024 s'était
fortement pressenti c'est désormais
officiel le comité d'organisation de
paris a proposé d'intégrer le breakdance
au programme des jo au parisien ce
serait une première pour ce sport qui
déjà tabarre apparu au pot jeux
olympiques de la jeunesse l'année
dernière on écoute la réaction de jean
jé mad cofondateur de la compagnie black
blanc beur ça me suggère un sentiment
paradoxal dire que d'un côté
voilà une ultime reconnaissance d'un
savoir faire deux choses extrêmement et
du corps et complexes beau à voir et qui
devient un sport de compétition c'est à
dire qui affirme nettement linverse
finalement de ce qui l'a amené à se
développer comme un genre stylistique de
la danse hip hop à savoir une danse qui
porte un récit qui porte un
questionnement politique
un questionnement culturel et qui a
abandonné se positionne justement non
pas contre la compétition mais pose
d'abord
la compétition qu'on a à voir en nous
mêmes et non le principe d'être au
dessus des autres avec le breakdance
l'escaladent pourrait faire son entrée
aux jeux olympiques de 2024 à paris
cette discipline pratiquée par plus d'un
million de personnes chaque année en
france et 4e sport le plus testé dans
les lycées et collèges a été retenu par
le comité d'organisation
nous sommes allés du côté de l'une des
plus grandes salles de bloc verticale
art situé à montigny le bretonneux pour
recueillir les réactions
personnellement je trouve que c'est une
avancée comme une conséquente pour le
sport dans sa globalité mais ceux-ci
quelque chose qu'ils voient qu'ils
étaient assez attendue au vu de
l'évolution du sport depuis ces cinq
dernières années
moi je trouve ça très bien ça va
permettre de démocratiser un petit peu
ce sport qui est très peu connue qui
commence à être un petit peu plus connus
ici en france notamment grâce aux salles
de bloc mais ça va permettre de les
faire venir encore un petit peu plus de
demandes dans le sport c'est une
reconnaissance
oui tout à fait enfin l'escaladent on
sait que c'est un sport complet des
ronds comprenais pas trop pourquoi
justement ce n'était pas reconnue au
niveau des jeux olympiques ça va donner
une autre dimension à ce sport elle ne
sera pas sport olympique la pétanque est
pourtant à la mode chez les jeunes
adultes avec quatre français sur dix
adeptes de cette discipline chez les 18
30 ans il était presque ils étaient
encore nombreux lors d'un tournoi
organisé par la pétanque que lui en
courtois ce dimanche au centre sportif
les trois mousquetaires à guyancourt
un montage de jules grandes villes
on a tiré et on a pointé à guyancourt le
club local a organisé ce dimanche 24
février au centre sportif les trois
mousquetaires son traditionnel tournoi
officiel niveau promotion un rendez-vous
en doublettes mixtes qui a tiré
principalement des joueurs des yvelines
c'est le premier de l'année donc oui
c'est un rendez vous important
il a fait très beau donc évidemment ça
ça joue beaucoup sur sur la journée nous
avons eu beaucoup d' équipe à peu près
une centaine d' équipe nous ne
l'espérions pas donc ça se passe très
bien
parmi les participants beaucoup de
seniors mais également une dizaine de
jeunes qui ont décidé de se lancer en
doublettes c'est le cas de saïd 28 ans
ce guillon courtois a commencé à
pratiquer la pétanque avec son beau père
aujourd'hui ce sportif en fait
régulièrement on va dire les jeunes ont
moins d'expérience donc du coup ils vont
pas forcément dans les compétitions mais
là ça prend de plus en plus de jeunes
qui sont là qui trouve qu'en fait bah
c'est pas simplement en sport on a dû
ronger 2 déboule mais ça demande de la
précision cette technique est bien plus
on progresse dans ce port là et pas plus
on voit que le sport en fête à haut
niveau est très difficile les jeunes et
les moins jeunes se retrouvent le 10
mars prochain pour un nouveau tournoi
officiel à guyancourt
l'occasion pour saïd de peaufiner encore
son geste on ouvre une page cyclisme
après 2015 le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueillera-t-il à nouveau un
championnat du monde sur piste c'est en
tout cas le souhait du président de la
fédération française michel callot un
dossier de financement est à l'étude et
va être montée d'ici le mois de
septembre organisé l'un des plus gros
rendez vous sur piste deux ans avant de
recevoir les jeux olympiques la décision
devrait bientôt être connu l'union
cycliste internationale devrait
attribuer les championnats du monde 2022
en septembre prochain
en attendant 2022 les pistards de
l'équipe de france participeront cette
semaine aux championnats du monde à
pruszkow en pologne
elle avait même organisé de ce mercredi
27 février à ce dimanche 3 mars sur la
piste on retrouvera notamment les
plaisirs aux à michael d'almeida et
sandie clair grégory baugé originaire de
maisons laffitte ainsi que mathilde de
gros pensionnaires du pôle olympique
saint quentin en yvelines
objectif de cette équipe de france
remportée au minimum trois médailles de
ces championnats du monde pour préparer
au mieux les jeux olympiques de tokyo
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]